hello my name is Mike Laurie and I'm
here today I talk about Bell's Theorem
in general and the issue of locality in
particular I am a retired engineer spent
most of my time in the airspace industry
now I'm retired I'm interested in using
Mathematica to follow my hobby of
physics subjects
one of the the key things here that that
I'm interested in is nonlocality
the whole thing that concerned Einstein
back during the 30s when they unstamped
Podolsky and Rosen wrote their famous
paper and then Bell's Theorem in 1964
which was a response to that the kind of
turned Bell's argument on Stein's
argument on its head and said reality
must be non-local Bell's Theorem is one
of the most important results in the
area of quantum theory foundations it's
also one of the most controversial
that's one of my interest in it for
example why is there still so much
activity conferences papers debates
surrounding this paper I looked up the
Google citations Google Scholar
citations for Bell John Bell it's not
decreasing its increasing Hey look 2017
there are over 6,000 papers that cited
John Bell one way or another now I'm not
saying that was all about the things I'm
about to talk about today but still
that's quite a bit of interest in that
very old paper the VAX geo conferences I
don't know how you pronounced that it's
a Swedish name run by Andrey chronic off
a Russian mathematician who runs these
conferences every year there's still
fish disagreements among the experts
another thing I would recommend you
looking at if you're interested or these
there's a paper and a corresponding
YouTube video by Tim maudlin where he
maintains that a lot of mainstream
physicists totally misunderstand what
I'm saying was concerned about and
therefore misunderstand what Bell
actually did it's not randomness but
depending the role of probability in QM
quantum mechanics but the implications
for nonlocality that really was
Einsteins concern and very mainstream
things like physics world has a video
out there where they completely say the
wrong thing about what Einstein was
concerned about so even today there's
concern about this or you know
controversy about this
okay Who am I to offer my two cents I'm
admittedly a complete novice and not a
complete novice I did take physics in
college but I got my degree in
mathematics and information theory
mostly I certain engineer or places like
NCR Raytheon but almost all my career at
Boeing as an aerospace engineer so I was
doing very practical things I wasn't
doing quantum theory but it's always
been a hobby of mine I got to learn
Mathematica at working on the job and
I'd love to use it in retirement two
years now and it's just so much fun to
use mathematic Mathematica to explore
ideas to try out things to draw pictures
you know do manipulates and interactive
graphics and discover things and then
try to prove them it's a very fun way to
approach it so keep in mind I'm an
amateur I've got some ideas that help me
understand Bell's Theorem maybe to help
other people whether they be amateurs or
professionals but anyway I'm just
telling you the facts here so you know
so what are we trying to do today three
things I'd like to show you a framework
that I've kind of developed for my own
understanding its probability models
with parameters I want to show how these
models relate to each other with a heavy
emphasis on diagrams and pictures and I
want to shed some light on the very
confusing relationships still debated
between realism and locality as defined
by Bell so here's just diving in to I'm
not going to do the traditional wave of
starting with the whole history of
Bell's Theorem I will do that later but
I just want to give you the punchline
here that I'm going to show you five
models three of them that really mean
something physical Bell local Bell real
and quantum mechanics the other two I
call maximum minimal are just sort of
containing or I'd say bookends to the
other three the maximal is like
Universal set that includes everything
in the minimal is like everything
includes it it's a singleton
it's those are sets of correlations that
I have in this partially hoarded lattice
so you'll see that bell local is
contained in Bell real and that's
contained in maximal and those Bell real
and Bell local are different than qm QM
is on a different path
there are intersections between these
two but neither one contains the other
hence it's not below or above QM quantum
mechanics in this diagram and I'll be
explaining a little more about what all
this means as we go along but I just
wanted to show you the main points of
this so a probability models Bell real
if all of the the so-called CH SH
inequalities hold that stands for
clauser horn shamone and halt who are at
a paper in 1969 which generalized bells
inequalities that's what I'm going to
talk about in this so whenever I say CH
SH just think Bell generalized if a
probability Miles Bell local then it's
also than all the inequalities hold
however if all the inequalities hold
it's not necessarily bell local now Bell
real are that's an if and only if Bell
local it's not if and only if the local
models are proper subset of the real
models and the kids I said the QM and
Bell real models don't have
intersections but neither one contains
the other now let me just again make a
disclaimer know that none of this is
well some of it is not new I think the
viewpoint is new but the result that I
just said it's not new number one is not
new that's just Bell's Theorem together
with finds theorem which he proved in
1982 there's Arthur fine and more
generally it's very interesting that
there's been a recent rediscovery as
there often is in mathematics and
physics of some really good work that a
russian mathematician did before Bell in
1962 in a Russian journalist 30
probability which was published in
English in the by Siam in their theory
of probability translation for up
or above any Russian speakers in here
I'm probably massacring the name biroba
of whatever it is did a very general
paper on consistent families of measures
which subsume all this stuff about bells
inequality but I don't think the quantum
physics ever physicists ever knew about
that and it isn't until recently you
start to see papers saying well why
didn't you look at this guy before well
he did pure mathematics and a physics
world probably didn't pay attention to
that so anyway here are some pictures I
want to get to the punchline first you
won't know exactly what all this means
yet and I will explain it and
subsequently but I just want to show you
in pictures kind of what I discovered by
trying to understand this on my own the
first row is a set of correlations of
what I'm going to be talking about
throughout this talk or correlations if
you know the famous experiment the EPR
experiment the aspect experiment you
have Alice and Bob who were separated by
a great distance an entangled system
sends one particle to Bob and one
particle Dallas and they do some
measurements and there's some
correlations that show up Alice has two
angles to set her measuring equipment at
Bob has two angles to set his equipment
hat together that makes four so there's
four possible correlations they can
measure so what you're looking at is
spaces of correlations which I'm going
to denote W XY and Z but human beings
don't think in 4d so I have to do slices
through the 4d space so each of these
five things that each row is a slice
through the correlation space of that
model with the W the first correlations
set to either minus 1 minus 1/2 0 1/2 or
1 so on the ends the left end is
complete anti correlation in the W
coordinate on the right is complete
correlation W equals 1 and in the middle
is no correlation in the W
ordinate zero now the first row is what
the quantum theory predicts for the
correlations now look at that and then
look at the Bell real row now what Bell
was trying to do was say suppose I
assume reality or locality can i
reproduce what quantum theory looks like
now there's a whole bunch of emphasis in
the literature on one number they look
at 2 & 2 times the square root of 2 or 2
numbers 2 & 2 times the square root of 2
Bell says you can't go higher than 2 for
a certain function of the correlations
quantum theory says oh yes I can I can
go all the way to 2 times the square
root of 2 and they focus on this all the
time and I think wait a second you got a
you guys guys have a model that
replicates that first row with all those
fancy swoopy pictures there and the next
two don't look like that at all
and then to go on I can put them
together and you can see in the first
that the Bell local models sit inside
the quantum theory the QM models on the
two ends in the middle that kind of
mixed up there inside and outside both
in the middle you see the same thing
with the Bell real models inside and
outside there some that are QM similar
or not QM that are Bell real and in the
third row the very interesting
relationship between Bell local and Bell
real is the Bell local models the green
the green I call them Pringles they're
like Pringles potato chips or hyperbolic
paraboloids
and they sit inside completely inside
the Bell real
that's why Bell local sits below but
Bell real in the partially ordered
lattice okay and then here's a picture
of the W equals zero case the red lines
are intersections between the quantum
mechanics predictions for the
correlations and the Bell local for the
W equals zero case so there is a way to
win the Bell game if you know what the
Bell game is for those values on the red
lines okay you'll learn I'll talk a
little more about this as I go along so
here's the history spooky action edition
bothered Einstein he and his two
postdocs wrote a paper in 1935 they say
if you take quantum mechanics and
locality there must be hidden variables
in other words quantum mechanics is
incomplete Bell reanalyzed the whole
argument 1964 he turned it around and
said well if I assume hidden variables
that is reality and locality I get a
prediction which is inconsistent with
quantum mechanics the devised derived an
inequality that was violated by quantum
mechanics then that set the stage for a
real lab experiment which aspect did in
1982 and people have continued to do
through the years and just last in the
last two years I think it was in 2015
three years ago they supposedly closed
all the so-called loopholes and bells
experiment and the aspect experiment so
now it's supposedly proved that Bell was
right that indeed if you assume reality
and locality you do not get quantum
mechanics so you've got to drop one of
the three you either don't believe in
quantum mechanics so you don't believe
in reality or you don't believe in
locality and locality means non locality
means like Einstein says spooky action
at a distance there are influences which
can travel faster than light that's what
you have to accept one of the things you
might have to accept depending on how
you choose okay so that's what bothered
Einstein he did say it seems hard God
plays dice but he also said uses
telepathic methods and Tim modelin
maintains if you watch that YouTube
video that it was really the telepathic
part that bothered Einstein he wasn't
suppose so concerned about indeterminacy
he is more concerned about spooky action
at a distance so I recommend you watch
that video it's very interesting model
is a very exciting speaker and a lot of
fun to watch and he stirs up a lot of
trouble so anyway it's a good place to
start
what's the experiment all about you have
a source which is a entangled a system
of two particles one sent to Alice once
sent to Bob they have to measuring
orientations each so total of four or
tations so they have Alice's angle a and
angle in crime bob has angle B and angle
B prime they get outputs plus or minus 1
it goes into a consistent coincidence
monitor which multiplies their 1 and
minus 1 plus or minus ones together they
get plus 1 they're coincident if they
get minus 1 it's anti coincident then
they separate all these results into
four bins depending on that on the angle
settings and then they compute
correlations for all of those the number
of pluses minus the number of minuses
over the number of pluses plus the
number of minuses which is always a
number between minus 1 and 1 as long as
the denominator is not 0 which we'll
assume it's not okay so to get those
correlations and then you do some
calculations with them and you compute
this s estimate this number s where you
put a minus sign in front of one of the
yet all the correlations together and
you put a minus sign in front of one of
them and doesn't matter which one and at
least one of them is going to have the
bell says the estimate has to be between
minus 2 and 2
quantum theory says quantum theory says
no you can be as big as 2 times the
square root of 2 or minus as low as
minus 2 times square root of 2 and those
bounds are sharp you can attain those
bounds with quantum theory and that's
the essence of Bell's Theorem if you
assume reality or locality this number
that you compute is going to be between
minus 2 and 2 but quantum theory says no
I can go beyond that ok so that's the
essence of what's going on there now
here's a picture of that this yellow
surface is the Bell sir I'm sorry the
quantum surface this is a different one
that I showed before it's as a function
of the angles which are over here 22 and
1/2 degrees between quantum by the way
quantum theory says the result that they
get the results they get only depends on
the difference between their angle
settings so it's not the angles a B
a-prime and b-prime that matter it's the
differences the 22 and a half 22 and a
half 22 and a having 67 and a half which
is the sum of the other three
this this point up here this purple dot
at the very top is the maximum quantum
mechanic deviation from the Bell surface
which is at two that's as high as it can
get the green plane is at the level two
that's the highest a bell real local
model can get whereas quantum mechanics
predicts I can go up here to this purple
dot so that's another way of seeing
Bell's Theorem okay and here it is in a
table you compute for the Bell model and
for the QM model you compute the
correlations then you compute and these
are the possible values this looks funny
here for the Bell model just think of
the the Rose row one through row 16 are
forms a PMF a probability mass function
they're nonzero real numbers which sum
to one
so you see that all these numbers are
between minus one and plus one and
obviously these cosines are between
minus 1 and plus 1 so these are
correlations these are the constraints
down here and then you compute these
functions as so-called
s functions which are represented the
functions are represented by this matrix
and you compute those two s functions
and in the bell case you can only get
between minus 2 and 2 in the quantum
mechanics case you can go as high as two
times square root 2 as low as 2 minus 2
times square root of 2 okay so that's
Bell's Theorem in a table and in a
figure now finally I'm going to give you
what my models are and this is kind of a
new thing this is my own invention
I mean they're waste it's equivalent a
lot of ways to the standard literature
but people don't look at it quite this
way I've modeled each model in exactly
the same way as a PMF that is a
probability mass function on a set of
outcomes
now the outcomes you'll see the letters
at the top here a be under outcomes a B
da and DB a is Alice's outcome she
always gets a minus 1 or plus 1 Bob
always gets a minus 1 or plus 1 D sub a
corresponds to at
Alyce's detector setting she has two
settings minus one and plus one
usually you denote that a and a prime
but I like to have these four top four
tuples of minus ones and plus ones which
makes it more convenient disa B is also
is bobs to angle settings either the
first angle setting minus one or the
second anarchy angle setting plus one
obviously there are sixteen outcome
possible outcomes
now the QM model says this is what QM
predicts that it's going to be the
probability these numbers all add up to
one in each column okay every column
they all add up to one it's a
probability mass function you get cosine
squared 1/2 cosine squared times Delta a
and Delta B was that mean well Delta a
is the probability that Alice makes her
first angle choice Delta a prime is the
probability she takes her second angle
choice and the same for Bob Delta B is
first angle choice Delta B prime the
second angle choice so now these are the
five models now if you have those five
models and this just explains that you
can read this later when you look it up
on the website you will get these
correlations and you'll notice then
again the correlations are denoted W X Y
and C for the maximum model you get
these funny-looking things you get the
cosine of two theta is for the QM model
you get the row combinations for the
Bell real and these funny things for the
bell local and the minimal is all zeros
now the Bell real you can easily see
that those are between minus 1 and 1 and
these are between QM between minus 1 and
1 it's a little harder to see that the
bell locals are but if you do a little
bit of math you can see that these are
also between minus 1 and 1 and then
finally you do the S functions and when
you do the S functions you get these
values for s1 s2 s3 and s4 it's the same
expression with the minus sign in a
different place and each row each column
you just change where the minus sign is
on the terms so you have the first one
you have minus cosine theta one and the
second one you have minus
second data to the other screen plus and
then you have minus cosine theta3 and so
on but anyway you get the same result
for a QM you get between -2 and square
or two for bail local labelled real it's
minus two and two and then you can prove
that these things are as they are just
have proved in here I'm not going to do
any of the purse they're all some are
harder some are easier but anyway you
can read those on your own later so yeah
so I guess I'm almost done but I can do
some other things here at the end if we
want to but let me just summarize what
I've done what I would like to do and
the questions remaining so I think I've
showed how to reframe the concepts of
Bell real and Bell local in terms of
probability models with parameters and I
think it helps it helps me understand
and understand what's going on and I
think I discovered a new thing that
people don't talk about even though it
may be obvious to some physicists to
just don't say it that you know they
talk about Bell's Theorem assuming
locality and reality well I would say
locality is a stronger condition in
reality if you have locality you have
reality but you can have reality without
having locality according to those
models and the pictures I showed you so
it's a little bit more nuanced and
interesting that it's usually described
in the standard literature and this
doesn't change what bill
proved because if you assume a if you
assume a model is the local then you get
bells inequality and then quantum theory
violates said inequalities so you still
have to come to the conclusion that if I
assume locality I can't have quantum
theory so we have to accept if you want
quantum theory you're going to have to
accept locale of nonlocality there's
instantaneous action at a distance so I
haven't revolutionized the world all
I've done is have a little more
pictorial and organized way to think
about it
what I think I've done here and I've
Illustrated that in protection in
pictures and well I guess I said this
other part already
so future work what I'd like to do is
refine these categories because there
are other categories that they talked
about in the literature so called remote
context independence a remote outcome
independence put those into the pictures
and I'd like to classify all the
intersections
I showed you some intersections were
those straight lines between QM and
Belle local which is kind of interesting
I'd like to do that for all the models
where can you play the Belle game and
then I'd like to do a closer examination
of all the literature because there's so
many terms as in determinism there's
reality counterfactual definis hidden
variables do all those mean the same
thing same things sometimes they're used
interchangeably sometimes they're used
in two in different ways it's very hard
to tell what people are talking about so
one of my job's is going to be to try to
understand all those definitions though
the people haven't put it in terms of
the models I've developed here so they
can be all one place so and then there's
some questions to just leave you with is
Belle locality the same time same same
thing as Einstein locality now Belle had
a mathematical definition and I've
showed you my definition here which
reflects his definition by the way if
you look at this later on the web on the
Wolfram website you'll be able to go
down and see why I called it Belle local
and why I called a Belle real I have
good reasons for doing that I derived it
from the standard definitions of just I
turned it into a different format is
that the same as an Einstein locality I
understand was interested in things
traveling faster than light but what
things I mean this correlation thing is
that the same thing as information
traveling that fast well no it isn't
there's a matter of factors that theorem
and quantum theory it's called - no
communication theorem which says you
can't transmit and permission
information faster than the speed of
light at least using this kind of an
experiment the Bell experiment so
does that mean the same thing I don't
know I still question it and then the
big question is underlying is there the
last question the big question to me and
the things I like to look into and
there's a lot of work going on in this
area though is there an underlying
deeper pre quantum theory which
simultaneously recovers all the cue and
predictions that they just emerge the
born rule and all that stuff just
emerges and is either local or it
explains how nonlocality works what is
known Calvin's nonlocality how do we
it's the taneous lee know about
something somewhere else how does that
work anyway that's what I'd really like
to answer but I just want a little small
way today anyway thank you very much
[Applause]